even stronger
80-proof how about that maintain the you
know Russian reputation and everything
so while I'm erasing I'm gonna start
talking on so so my talk is going to be
about discrete objects because you know
I'm from the Midwest and the Midwest
we're all very discreet
and thank you John so perfect so I'm
going to look at two problems from
discrete probability or discrete
stochastic processing problems they're
related to Markov chain Monte Carlo and
correlation decaying graphical models
and we'll see how one can actually coax
a lot of interesting bounds out of what
one would call strong data processing
inequality so I use it in a different
sense although what what John has talked
about is related I'm gonna start by
looking at two spaces finite sets x and
y and I'm going to have a stochastic
mapping with input in X and output and Y
call that mapping K so it's a you can
think about it as a stochastic matrix
one convenient way of thinking about it
instead of transforming input symbols
into output symbols you can think about
taking an input distribution mu on X and
generating an output distribution mu K
on Y and so this is K and this notation
actually is supposed to be suggestive of
the fact that you can think about
probability distributions over finite
sets as row vectors in that case K will
be a matrix and transforming
distributions to distributions is
multiplication by that matrix from the
right equivalently you can think about
going in the opposite direction you can
think about a function f and I'm gonna
denote all real valued functions on the
set by F of that set that function is
going to be mapped to another function
call it KF and that function is going to
be a function on on X so you can think
about K acting in two different
directions the idea is that this is just
the duality between row and column
vectors or duality within measures and
functions so the ordinary data
processing equality says that if I were
to fix mu and then look at the result of
passing that through K and then I would
take some other distribution new pass
that through K and then compare them in
a sense of relative entropy we know that
the ratio of the output relative entropy
to the input relative entropy is less
than or equal to 1 and that's that's
just a standard data processing
inequality what I call strong data
processing equality is is as follows
first of all I'm going to fix mu and
call out my reference distribution
reference measure and I'm going to look
at the supremum of this ratio over all
news that are distinct from mu News
fixed and if this is less than some
constant C which is less than 1 then I'm
going to say that K satisfies strong
data processing inequality with constant
C at MU okay better marker
there's a Dominator of infinity I'm
sorry
so okay so in order in order to avoid
that unpleasant situation I'm going to
assume here that mu has strictly
positive masses everywhere right if I'm
not if I'm in a finite set situation
that's not gonna happen so much better
and in fact we can't we can play this
game with any other measure of
divergence so in particular let's
introduce something called the fie
divergence so I'm you know committing a
bit of a blasphemy here because normally
one talks about F divergences I use F
for functions so I'm going to talk about
functions fee from non-negative reals
into reals I'm gonna assume this
function is convex and I'm going to
assume that fee of 1 is equal to 0 and
then I'm going to define the fee
divergence between nu and mu simply as
the expectation under mu of fee of nu
divided by mu and this is of course the
broader nikodem derivative but you know
I'm in a discrete setting there's no
need to get all fussy with that so mu I
assume is it charges all points so this
ratio is is is never never divergent and
I'm going to then talk about obviously
strong data processing equality of let's
say with constant C at mu of type fee if
this holds and I'm gonna omit all
mention a fee fee is just the function T
log T so in particular fee of t is equal
to t log t then the corresponding fee
divergence is just the relative entropy
if fee is t minus 1 quantity squared
then this fee divergence is called the
chi-squared divergence if V of T is
1/2 absolute value of t minus 1 then the
corresponding fee divergence is the
total variation distance which of course
is also a metric but you know write it
this way so no because what I did it
what I did is I put mu in the
denominator so and that so so because I
always want the reference measure to be
in the second slot of the divergence now
and and strong data processing qualities
actually have a very very long history
the first paper I know off that you
explicitly consider it in the case of
divergence is a remarkable paper by all
sveta and GOC from the 70s with 76 right
so in gosh my handwriting is terrible
1976 among other things and this is not
the only result in paper by far but
among other things they proved that so
let's define and an SDP I constant a
taffy have mu and K obviously as the
supreme um overall news that are not
equal to mu of the ratio the output you
input V divergences right so what I'll
say that in gosh prove as I said this is
just a minor result not paper but you
know at least it shows you something
interesting they prove that the relative
entropy so one I don't write fee that
means relative entropy of the reference
measure being just a fair coin toss
Bernoulli 1/2 and the channel is the
binary symmetric channel with parameter
epsilon this is equal to exactly 1 minus
2 epsilon squared so since then the
arbitrary divergence was taken up by
Cohen at all I think that paper has like
six authors 1993
they showed some interesting things
first of all they looked at the case
where you define a Daffy FK simply by
supervising over the reference
distribution and they showed the
following they showed that for any fee
and for UK this is bounded by the de
Bruijn constant of the channel so
maximum overall input letters total
variation distance between the
corresponding output distributions so
this holds for any fee and moreover they
also showed that this is equal to the
total variation contraction coefficient
of that channel so you know look at look
at look at let Phoebe absolute one-half
epsilon Q minus 1 super mais overall
news this is exactly achieved they also
show the lower bound on a taffy
if fee is three times differentiable and
strictly convex in the neighborhood of
one and then they showed that in that
case a taffy Wow is lower bounded by a
two chi squared and a de chi squared so
in fact you can so so they show this by
supervising overall Mews you can
actually show this point wise so it's a
it's a Taylor series it's a Taylor
expansion argument that works precisely
the same way but you can show that and
we're gonna use that you can show that a
de fee of Miu K for any fee satisfying
the same conditions three times
differentiable strictly conducts in the
neighborhood of one is lower bounded by
the chi squared as dpi coefficient which
by the way also has an exclusive
expression it's the so-called squared
maximum correlation where maximum
correlation coefficient and this goes
back to the holes has a rich history
there's a paper
right my Hirschfeld rainy Gabba lines
Armand off whitson housing looked at it
so this is the supremum over all
functions on X and on G the expected
value of f of X times G of Y where the
conditions are G 0 mean and F is zero
mean and unit variance one where x and y
here X has long mu and Y conditioned on
X has lock a condition locking so you
know Joint Distribution o of x and y so
so this this is this is a lower bound
and that holds point wise from you and
before I go on to you know applications
to graphical models I want to actually
show a quick proof of this result which
actually is not trivial it rests on a
very very sharp and equality having to
do with a contraction of signed measures
on their Markov kernels proved in this
paper I want to show a proof of the
special case when the stochastic
transformation QK satisfies something
called the dublin type mineralization
condition which is gonna be related to
what john was showing so i'm gonna go
over here and quickly write out that
proof and then i'm going to launch into
graphical models this proof is actually
unrelated to the graphical models was
kind of kind of a nice information
theoretic demonstration so suppose that
suppose that my k is such that suppose I
can find a constant alpha greater than 0
and a probability measure mu tilde on
the output alphabet such that K of Y
given X as a transition probability for
y upon receiving X is upper lower
founded by alpha times u tilde of Y for
all x and y then we can just show that
for any eight a fee of K is less than 1
minus alpha and the way you prove it is
is a nice information theoretic proof so
consider the following consider consider
implementing K in the following way
so let me enumerate the letters in X by
0 1 let's say M minus 1 and I have the
following eraser type channel 0 1 minus
1 and on the output I have 0 1 and minus
1 but I also have a special oratio
symbol and each letter goes into itself
with probability 1 minus alpha and gets
erased with probability alpha same thing
here if I have such a channel I can by
observing just the output of that I can
simulate k how do I do that notice by
this condition I can define another
channel K tilde which now also between x
and y as follows just simply take K Y
minus K Y your next minus alpha u tilde
Y divided by Y minus 1 minus alpha and
by this condition this is a bona fide
channel so if I see an honor a symbol I
push it through this if I see a ratio I
just generate a fresh sample from u
tilde and you can see by you know by
just manipulating things that that's the
the composition of that that that
channel conditionally on you know
whether you see an underage thing an
hour or an erasure gives me K and that
means that the divergence anythi
diversions between UK and UK is going to
be upper bounded by the divergence let's
call this erasure channel e alpha
divergence between mu e alpha and mu e
alpha and that
is just by convexity of divergences is
less than 1 minus alpha diversions
between you and you so you can see that
this actually admits a very nice
operational proof that you can actually
show that if a channel satisfies this
fairly strong condition then it can be
simulated by passing through an erasure
channel ok so now that I've shown you
these things let me show you two
applications of strong data processing
inequalities to two problems and
discrete probability but one for sure
and then depending on how much time I
have left another one how much time do I
have lost by the way ok I'll show them
just why application and then you know
if I get to PI if I get to be picked the
lucky winner then I'll show you the
other one tomorrow 7:00 ok excellent
maybe maybe there's a chance I see you
yeah and you think anything to prevent
me from giving the early morning talk
excellent I'll sleep longer ok so so
let's let's let's consider the Phong
problem suppose I have a graph G ve I
assume it's simple no loops or multiple
inches and undirected and and then I
pick a number I pick a natural number Q
right so natural number it well well no
no no no self loops no self loops yeah
it's not a tree no self loops
ok so Q is a number of colors an idea is
it as I'm gonna take my as a my input
and output alphabet is gonna be the set
of all colorings of g with Q colors
where I say that an element X which is
of course just an assignment of colors
to vertices is a proper coloring what
everybody knows with proper coloring
proper Q coloring if
whenever you and V are connected by an
edge that implies that the colors are
different and we know that the number of
colors number of proper colorings of g
with cue colors this is a polynomial in
Q but it's np-hard to compute so ones
one nice thing you could do is instead
of counting it you could sample from the
set of all proper colorings and then do
something like support size estimation
right to determine the value of this
because the connection between counting
and sampling is well-known but even
sampling from proper colorings is
difficult so what you do is you relax it
and you consider so lets you know by
strictly not two confusable
distributions you instead consider
sampling from a relaxed version so you
could call it the cue Potts model and
you pick a parameter beta and then you
have the following probability
distribution on colorings up to a
normalization constant which is the
partition function you have the
exponential of beta times the product of
all the edges and then you penalize
every time you violate the constraint so
even sampling from that is difficult
directly so instead there are two there
are two well-known techniques for doing
it one is the heat bath so Heath bath
works like this and it's it's it's going
to be a channel right so K heat bath
gonna map probability distributions on
on colorings to probability
distributions and colorings pick a
vertex uniformly at random sample from
the conditional distribution on that
vertex given its neighbors because it's
a Gibbs field
replace leave all the other vertices
untouched and we know that the Gibbs
Distribution is invariant with respect
to that
stochastic transformation and it's easy
to implement because of the locality
property of this thing
the other well-known algorithm is called
Swenson Wong so this goes by heat bath
goes back to Roy Glauber his working
life 1960's swanson wang is published in
nineteen put 87 or something like that
it's it's a bit more complicated than
that the idea is that for any for any
configuration x let me associate it with
a set a x of edges such that X U is
equal to X V where edge is this UV right
so all edges that that violate the
constraint what you do to sample from
one iteration of of the Swensen long is
the following
it's another mark of kernel it's easier
to describe them in words than to write
down you if your current configuration
is X you look at the set of all the
edges where the constraints where the
colouring constraint is violated each
edge you delete independently with
probability one minus e to the minus
beta then you end up with a graph so you
end up with a graph where you take the
original vertex set whatever is left
after a deletion process is the set of
edges that graph in general is going to
be disconnected what you're gonna do is
you're gonna pick a color uniformly at
random for each connected component and
color all the vertices with that color
and and so again Swensen long the Gibbs
measure is invariant so people use heat
bath because it's easy to implement and
empirically Swanson Wong seems to be
fast for graphs at least you know 4 4 4
4 interesting graphs with a small number
of colors however there are situations
where sweats and Wong is slow and
there's nothing you can do about that so
in 2012 mario ulrich proved an
interesting result which amounts to in
my language amounts to
following statement that one minus
square root of the chi-squared
contraction coefficient of the sweats n'
wong kernel is greater than the
following ugly-looking constant 1 over 2
Q for Delta plus 2 e to the 8 beta Delta
Delta is the maximum degree of the graph
times 1 minus square root of the
corresponding contraction coefficient
for the heat bath so I'm gonna show you
an improvement of this bound that works
for all fees that use an entropy
invariant under scaling so awkward
that's because I'm not from California
so the proof is based on a very very set
one very simple idea and one very
ingenious idea of Ullrich the simple
idea is mine the ingenious ideas due to
over if the simple idea is this so it's
a comparison principle for comparison
principle for strong data process
processing constants and it says the
following suppose I have a distributor
I'm going to state a simple formula
except what's supposed to have a
distribution mu and two stochastic
transformations K and K bar on from the
same input set to the safe to the same
output set suppose that maximum over all
x and y K bar Y given X divided by K Y
of X is less than or equal to some
constant a then a de fée of MU K is less
than or equal to 1 minus 1 over a 1
minus a 2 fie mu K bar if fie satisfies
a mild condition Phi is a homogeneous
condition
all it says is that if I were to look at
this expression expectation of any
function of fee of some positive random
variable mu - fee expectation of you if
I were to scale you by a positive
constant this quantity would be scaled
by some function of that constant so in
particular fee when you get the T log T
that satisfies that t minus 1 squared
satisfies that so we're gonna use this
and and this is actually this follows
from a from again a Taylor series type
of an argument where you represent fie
divergence as a tale of a Taylor series
expansion so there's a comparison
principle and it holds for all possible
situations now I'm going to now I'm
going to use this yes this this is the
spectral gap no not quite it's it's
related to that but but but it's not as
strong as it could be essentially here's
what it does and it's a brilliant idea
he says ok instead of considering
comparing so Watson long to heat bath
I'm gonna define the following
stochastic kernel I'm gonna run heat
bath then on top of that I'm gonna run
sweat some one I'm gonna run heat bath
again
so because of these invariant variance
properties that gives distributions
invariant under K and he also proves
that in fact if you look at any two
colorings the ratio of this kernel to
the Swensen Wong kernel is bounded by Q
to the power 2 Delta plus 1 e to the 4
beta Delta now if I knew something about
the data processing constant of K I'd be
in business and I do because remember
this invariance condition so it means
that for any other distribution you and
then take my gifts distribution ki be
beta Q this is gonna be bounded by the
square of the heat bath cons that I'm
not gonna write out everything and this
one's in one constant times the
divergence between nu and the Gibbs
measure once you realize this then you
just invoke the comparison principle
rearrange and then you get the following
bound which I'm gonna write out and then
I think it's my time to gracefully exit
gracefully or or disgracefully so so so
here's the bound which which strengthens
Ullrich I mean that they're not that
great either of them because of the
exponents but but mine is slightly
better so the bound says the following
you just write it down and they'll be
you to Delta plus 1 e to the 4 beta
Delta minus 1 divided by Q 2 to Delta
plus 1 e to the 4 beta Delta minus
square of the path and that's so this is
you know it's better than Ulric but
because of these exponents I mean none
of them are that great so anyway thanks
a lot I can't see who's asking the
question because my eyesight is horrible
I'm trying to recall exactly what a
normal twist is long if I recall
correctly if you have a so this is not
the color inside if you have an
affirming there's easy model.we feedback
dynamics doesn't work in high dimension
when your local face position points
right right yes so you would expect to
see this type of qualitative change in
anything you think about the special
results but as far as I can tell I don't
really it's hard to figure out the
notation but as far as I can tell your
results or lures result doesn't say
anything about this way you wants to
erase it immediately no I mean here's
here well here's here's the main result
there's nothing incriminating here's the
main result I mean all this result says
the following if if if he back fix is
fast so what's in long is gonna mix even
faster if so what's the long is slow
heat bath is gonna be slow as well but
it doesn't show that there are regions
in the phase space where the each map is
really bad and no it doesn't and I think
woliver has the same sort of same sort
of situation because I mean what you
would want is you would want these
spectral gaps to be reasonably dependent
on only squad quantities you know in
some in some meaningful way like for
example you would say that somehow you
want mixing time to be let's say you
know sub polynomial and some parameters
of the graph then you have to invoke
these
you know the bruising uniqueness or the
bruising Schwarzman or something like
that to say something about that - you
know invoke a specific value of the
other entropy contraction constant here
otherwise yeah I mean it's insensitive
to to the question of phase transitions
okay so we take a break and with the
back end